[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie so this
morning if you didn't see the internet
was going crazy because everyone thinks
that Henry Cavill is going to be the new
version of Wolverine in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so I'll explain why
that is and what's really going on with
x-men during Marvel phase 4 because even
though some of the rumors you might hear
aren't true there is x-men stuff
happening during Marvel phase 4 if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's gonna be a bunch of big stuff
coming up we're doing that big infinity
saga box set giveaway for all the
blu-rays all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what you
want them to do with the x-men during
Marvel phase 4 so we'll just break this
down top 5 style starting with number 5
if you didn't see it earlier today a
bunch of websites and low-level blogs
were reporting that Henry Cavill was
going to play Wolverine in Captain
Marvel 2 of all movies which Marvel is
getting ready to film next year we know
the Captain Marvel 2 is happening
they've already confirmed it but already
you should start seeing some red flags
when you hear Captain Marvel 2 in
Wolverine mentioned in the same sentence
but naturally the internet did the thing
that it always does when a fan favorite
actor everybody loves henry cavill is
rumored to be playing such a popular
character that everyone has been
wondering about for a couple years now
since Hugh Jackman said that he wasn't
going to be doing Wolverine anymore of
course everyone wants to know what's
gonna happen with the future of the
Wolverine character so a little while
after that what happened was is that a
ton of higher-level legitimate news
websites picked up the rumor and it's
sort of spreading like wildfire without
anyone really bothering to get
confirmation even websites like just
jerod in Entertainment Tonight Canada
legitimate websites that post behind the
scene pictures for major movies and do a
lot of legitimate coverage of stuff did
whole articles about Henry Cavill
Wolverine written as if he were actually
going to be doing it thankfully most of
you probably saw the headlines did a
double-take and had the good sense to
realize that it's probably not true for
a number of reasons
but we have to acknowledge number four
WTF yes there is major x-men plans in
the MCU right now Kevin Feige confirmed
back at the Marvel phase four Comic Con
panel last summer that they are working
on new x-men movies and integrating
mutants into the MCU movies this is a
clip of him explaining how that's going
to happen in how the Marvel x-men the
new
Marvel x-men will look different from
the Fox x-men are you guys not looking
to go the route of a traditional x-men
titled movie for those characters I was
mutants an x-men are interchangeable I
just said I just said mutants but yes
whatever we do will be quite different
than what's been done before super
quickly
Wyatt Blade now and why Marv Herschel
ever do the same answer late now because
of my her solo and my her slow because
he looks so what he saying means a lot
of different things when he says
Marvel's x-men are gonna be different
he means the characters will be
introduced in a very different way the
new core x-men MCU team will come
together in a very different way they'll
look very different isn't they'll be
different actors because they'll be
recast not including Deadpool Ryan
Reynolds will still be Deadpool don't
worry about that but physically they'll
also be wearing very different looking
costumes
obviously everybody points to the
example of Wolverines yellow comic book
costumes that Hugh Jackman always
laughed at and refused to wear they even
had a whole joke in the Logan movie of
how x-23 was this big x-men fan and it
grown up reading the comics thinking
that Wolverine ran around in a yellow
costume like that and then Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine tells her no we did
have adventures but they didn't look
like that and I didn't wear a costume
like that you may remember that Kevin
Feige did have early Marvel phase 1
plans before the first Avengers movie to
integrate x-men and even Spiderman into
the MCU there was this deleted scene of
an Iron Man post-credit scene where Nick
Fury comes to recruit Iron Man of the
Avengers initiative in the deleted scene
Nick Fury references X Man and
spider-man verbally which because it was
happening in 2008 also implies that it
would have been Tobey Maguire's
spider-man 2 crossover with the Avengers
and this was all for the first Avengers
movie mutants weren't enough I have to
deal with a spoiled brat doesn't play
well with others and wants to keep all
his toys to himself
Marilyn Nick Fury director of shield I'm
here to talk to you about the Avenger
initiative Oh what are we avenging
whatever the hell we want the reason why
there was no x-men avengers crossover
back then or even spider-man
crossover is because at the time Kevin
Feige couldn't reach a deal with Fox or
Sony for the characters took him more
than 10 years but were finally there we
finally got x-men we finally got
spider-man back currently there is some
x-men stuff happening in the Wan
division episodes that are going to be
airing later this year I'll explain that
in a second number three WTF oh Henry
Cavill can't play Wolverine practically
mostly because he's locked down under
contract for The Witcher Netflix for
multiple years and multiple seasons toss
a coin to your Witcher he did a great
job during season 1 there are all kinds
of compilation videos out there of him
grunting angrily for hours and dropping
f-bombs and I know a lot of people are
also claiming that he couldn't play
Wolverine because he's so huge
he's literally massive I don't consider
that a knock against him potentially
playing someone like Wolverine I mean
Hugh Jackman was over six feet tall and
he was a great Wolverine if you're not a
big comic book reader though the reason
why a lot of people complain about
Wolverine being too tall is because in
the comics he's supposed to be closer to
five three which is tiny by comparison
to people like Hugh Jackman who are way
over 6 feet if you weren't around for it
way back when they first cast Hugh
Jackman people complain for that very
same reason and if you can believe it
when they were getting ready for that
first Fox x-men movie back in 2000 the
most popular fan cast for the Wolverine
character was Bob Hoskins so it just
goes to show you that internet fan
casting does not always lead to the best
pairings of actors with characters just
because an actor looks like a character
doesn't mean that they'll be good in the
role or that the movie will be good you
also have to keep in mind that Henry
Cavill still wants to be Superman at DC
and if he were to do any kind of role no
matter how small at Marvel that would be
the nail in the coffin to him never
being Superman again number two WTF the
other big red flag and those rumors
about Wolverine should be that he's
going to appear for the first time in
Captain Marvel 2 a space-based character
why would Wolverine of all people of
debut in a Captain Marvel movie it just
sounds ridiculous those two characters
don't have any real comic-book history
together they've only loosely interacted
during big crossovers there are a
billion other Marvel characters that
would be a better fit for Captain Marvel
too like giving adult
Rambow her comic book powers after she
shows up in one division as an adult
she's working as an agent of sword for
Nick Fury during the events of the one
division episodes don't know exactly
what she's doing and we don't know if
she has powers yet but then there's also
the blue Marvel character also fan
favorite comic book character who just
spent a couple years in the ultimate
comics in outer space with Captain
Marvel if you don't want to wait for the
first full blown Marvel x-men movie and
Marvel phase 5 to introduce Wolverine
again a Wolverine vs. Hulk movie would
probably be the best place to put him
because he debuted in the comics for the
very first time in the Incredible Hulk
comics so why not introduce him in a
Hulk movie in number one WTF the current
x-men stuff right now that's happening
in the MCU on wan division is through
Scarlet Witch and visions comic book
children the twins Wiccan and speed that
they're doing on the TV show you all saw
the Wanda vision trailer there's a
couple scenes where they jump forward in
time through the decades as if they're
living in a couple of different sitcoms
through the years she starts out in
black and white in a 1950s sitcom
looking like Donna Reed or the Dick Van
Dyke Show where she gets married a
vision when they jump forward into the
70s in a very Brady Bunch looking house
she's super pregnant with the twins then
they jump into the 80s and it looks kind
of like family ties the twins were in
bassinets looking like they're
levitating their pacifiers with their
powers then they jump forward into the
90s and it looks more like Roseanne and
it seems like there's a bunch of kid
drawings on the fridge like they've
become grade schoolers in their much
older Kevin Feige said that they're
going full-blown comic-book scarlet
witch during the series so I think it's
implied that she's going to help create
these realities and then once it seems
like they're going to crumble she
refuses to let the children die with the
reality and finds a way to bring them
back into the real world that way you
have a Wiccan in speed that can then go
on to crossover with any future Young
Avengers project or any other Disney
Plus series or movies that you would
want to put them in so that's our
full-blown x-men stuff happening inside
the blonde division series but obviously
a lot of people just want to know where
the core x-men characters like Cyclops
Wolverine Jean Grey Professor X Magneto
when are they going to show up so there
is x-men stuff happening during Marvel
phase 4 but just don't expect to see
Wolverine for a long time and don't
expect it to be Henry Cavill when he
does
show up so if it wasn't clear from my
video I'm saying that the Henry Cavill
Wolverine rumors are probably not true
everyone let me know in the comments
when do you want them to do a new
version of Wolverine in the MCU and
who's the actor you want to be that new
bull Vereen I've got a couple other
Marvel phase 4 videos that I'm working
on the venom 2 trailer will be dropping
in the next month or two there'll be a
bunch more Morbius trailers and more
spider-man crossover Easter eggs so
everyone click here for my brand new
spider-man 3 video and click here for
all my new Avengers infinity Saga
deleted scenes thank you so much for
watching everyone stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]